so my next question again - George's
kind of continues on the issue of the
political implications so for all the
enormous interest and lauding of your
work certainly deservedly Spokeo
there have also been some critiques I'm
sure you know of the series by which I
mean both the book series on the TV
series political and social implications
now in many ways we could say that the
series really kind of undermine
traditional notions of power that they
really in some ways very much play with
you know as we've talked about about
phallic constructions of power kind of
subverting it but at the same time you
know there has been some critique of the
works in terms of issues of gender and
sexuality and race so for example with
the TV series that even led to the
coinage of a new term sex position right
which people talk about it you kind of
laugh about the way that sometimes
they'll be these scenes with with sexual
activity or nudity to kind of prevent
the information of narrative kind of
narrative information from seeming
boring that you have the sex going on so
some people say okay so women and sexual
minorities are therefore just kind of
titillation purposes and not much else
and there have also been some critique
of some of the racial tropes for
instance using the trope of the kind of
white savior of dark people like in the
case of Daenerys Targaryen so I'm
curious do you think that these
critiques are justified how do you
respond to those critiques
well you that question covers a lot of
territory there there let me try to
separate that into component parts here
first of all you have to separate the
books from the television I know they're
there they're two different things and
sometimes it's very very very clear as
in the case of this white Savior
business with the the scene with
Daenerys where she is hailed by the
slaves that she's just freed in the city
of yokai that scene is drawn largely
from the books but in the in the book
site I think I make it very clear that
the slavery of slavers Bay of yunkai and
hasta poor and marine is not racially
based it's not American slavery which
was strictly race-based it's modeled
much more on the the slavery of the
ancient Near East of the Romans and the
Greeks where slaves could be of any race
you know it could just be the guys at
Wilson last war
you know the Greeks enslaved each other
you know if Thebes defeated Athens in a
war a bunch of Athenians would suddenly
be slaves and thieves and vice versa the
Romans conquered people of various
colors in Africa and very different
covers and colors in Germany and goal
and made slaves of them all and that's
certainly what I depict in the books and
I think that's what is meant to be
depicted in the TV show - but no
practicalities wood running a TV show
those those scenes were filmed in
Morocco and the people that you see are
extras who are paid you know thirty
dollars a day or something like that -
to perform
to be in the background when you film
that the practicalities are you put out
a call for extras and people show up and
and you sign up as many as you need when
you'd be that in Morocco Moroccan show
up
so I don't know what the I mean
obviously there's an implication there
that people took of it perhaps people
who had not read the books that one of
the people that she freed were brown or
black and that's certainly not the was
not intended to be the case but on the
other hand flying in people from from
Ireland to in order to yeah people this
scene in Morocco just to stand in the
crowd would have been very very cost
prohibitive these are the kind of
practicalities of television production
that's that some critics never taken to
advantage I mean if you look at the
Dothrak I for example we filmed these
Dothraki scenes with Daenerys in a
number of different places and you know
like some of the early scenes our main
location is Belfast in Northern Ireland
and we film in areas around Belfast now
Danny in particular has filmed scenes in
Morocco in Malta she's filming some in
Spain right now we move around what some
of the early death rocaille scenes when
she's first with Khal Drogo or actually
filmed in in the fields outside Belfast
in Northern Ireland in forests and
grasslands and if you look at those
closely there's a lot of kind of pasty
white nothing right because those are
the guys who showed up when we put a
casting call yeah hey do you have long
hair can you ride a horse and you know
you hire who you show up and I mean
that's senior you know with with
Daenerys - I mean ties to the gender
issues I know what you're saying about
the differences between the TV show in
the book that it's very different let's
say the issues of sexual violence that
are in the TV program are not like the
scene you know that it is not a rape of
Danny and in your book and I know that
so I I understand exactly what you're
saying about that that between the
difference between the television and
but as you know but you're also an
executive producer of the TV series do
you have can you kind of negotiate those
things with them or you know how does
that work to say I don't like the way
your you're translating this you know
I'm involved in a television show but
it's it's really run by David Benioff
and
you know and I don't consult every day
I'm not I'm not in Belfast I'm I'm you
know in Santa Fe trying to half world
away trying to finish my books so I do
consult with them they we talk regularly
they sometimes ask my opinions and
sometimes they don't but I don't think
in them in that particular case I would
have done anything different I mean
frankly I don't even think I realized
there was a problem there until people
started pointing out there was a problem
maybe that's my blindness or the
blindness of David and Dan but it was
just you know the practicalities if
you're going to do that see I mean how
do you how do you get that where do you
get the mixed racial things when you're
trying to hire a thousand extras for a
scene and you're doing it in Morocco I
don't know you know do you use CGI to to
change their complexion or do you know
Jews say we have enough brown people
sorry we're not hiring anymore you brown
people you know only white people should
I don't know I don't know how you how
you do that but I don't know maybe there
is a better way and we should have
thought about it more but I don't know
that now let me go to another part of
that question which is the sex position
question that was a very cool coinage
which was coined by I think it was Miles
not yes miles not yeah referring to it
but one particular scene yeah and I
think they was probably justified for
that particular scene Littlefinger is
giving a long speech in the brothel and
meanwhile there's there's a couple girls
getting it onto the background
and it was parodied on Saturday Night
Live and all that but I do think that
like many of these tropes that or these
corners have come forward it's it's been
met vastly misused people don't seem to
actually understand the scene have
started applying it to any scene that
has sex
I don't think sexuality is sex position
you know sex position was that one
particular thing where they're trying to
put something I guess visually
interesting on behind on the scene while
there while someone was delivering uh
you know a long nugget of backstory
George let me let me come at this from a
different way because there's another
side to your characters another side to
what you're doing as you illuminate any
rolling stone interview from a from
maybe about a year ago you derived the
fact that fantasy is mostly inundated
with evil ugly Dark Lord's who go to
battle with dashing brave heroes and
you've kind of turned that paradigm
upside down I don't have a follow up to
Tom on this in a second your books
feature a dwarf as a major character if
not the sole the most reasonable voice a
disabled boy many of the characters a
prostitute plays several seem to be wise
and heroic you have a character who
commits in the first book and the first
season of the show an irredeemable act
who is now in the color since he's lost
a limb is becoming almost I I hesitate
to say heroic and yet that's what it is
you seem to have changed the nature of
heroism as it has been traditionally
defined in fantasy and science fiction
is that something you set out to do
consciously or just or did it evolve did
characters like Tyrion bran and Jaime
Lannister did they just evolve
organically
you know I think it's a little bit of
both I've always been attracted to great
characters I think they're more
interesting than than heroes you know
who are just going around being heroic
all the time
is that why bike taking Jamie's hand
away
he becomes a more sympathetic character
and seeks redemption instead of
continuing on the path he was on before
well he certainly has to read to find
himself and in that comes a lot of
personal anguish and personal growth and
personal struggle all of which is you
know great material for uh for drama you
know I grew up as a comic book fan as I
mentioned that was my first stuff was
published in comic fanzines and a huge
influence on me when I was like 10 11 12
years old was was Stan Lee and the
Marvel comics and there was one of the
things he did you know I'd been reading
DC Comics for years when Marvel started
and did he see stories were all
completely circular you know Batman was
looking around Gotham City and you know
here comes the Riddler or the Joker and
he defeats the Rigler under Joker and
they go in but they're never any
surprises the story ends right where
begins so next week he can you know
would poison ivy or whatever and you
always knew he'd hear us well you always
know who the villains were and Stanley
three through let out yes sir he you
know the Fantastic Four what a
revelation that was in 1961 you know one
of one of the guys on the team was a
monster and he didn't like being a
monster and he was angry at the other
people on a team they were fighting
within each other that Justice League
never fought within each other and I
discovered really the powers of conflict
and the powers of great characters and
they continued to I mean I love lorded
reins and I think Boromir is my favorite
character he's the one who who succumbs
you know he's a hero but he's also
fatally flawed and you know he fails at
the last moment and and you know you're
rooting for him but then and Peter
Jackson's a great job in the movie was
showing his temptation you really really
like Boromir but you know then he turns
against Frodo corrupted by the ring but
then he does so ugly full of arrows
Sean Bean dying one of his many deaths
[Applause]
so I love to write about characters like
that and intellectually I always I also
I also find the question of redemption
fascinating maybe it's you know I'm not
religious now but I was raised a
Catholic so maybe it's maybe it's
questions that I that come to me from my
whole Catholic upbringing and the things
I learned from my sister Mary elephant
or something in catechism
I mean you know that the whole question
of forgiveness for sin you know that the
Catholic Church teaches you go to
confession and you were forgiven for
your sins even terrible sins but
certainly our society doesn't
necessarily doesn't necessarily deal
with that we we don't forgive people
even I don't forgive people I recognize
you know I'm a great character myself
here I'm you know as some of you know
following my blog I'm a I'm a football
fan I'm a fan of the Giants and the Jets
but it bothers me - Michael Vick is on
my is on my Jets team and I know he's
paid his debt to society and all of I
can't just bring myself to root for this
guy yeah so you know and and then um
people say well what about your belief
and we're done well yeah I know but it's
still it's hard it's part